crime doesn't pay but scum sure does a
great job at punishing you for your
virtual wrongdoings by placing you into
this savage world of survival it's a
hard game and can be intimidating to
gain - especially when you see your
metabolism screen but to help you
survive and save your time when you
start playing we've put together some
beginners tips for those of you just
starting out on your sentence sticks and
stones may break your bones and that's
exactly why we want them the first thing
you should do when starting out is
search the ground in wooded areas for
some small stones as it'll be with these
you'll be able to craft a small stone
knife you can use this for basic defense
but also to start crafting yourself a
more versatile Arsenal on top of this if
you cut down some bushes you can craft
yourself a few wooden Spears these will
help you keep other inmates living or
dead at bay and you can also use them to
instantly kill zombies with a well-aimed
headshot the Spears are also going to
come in extra useful once you manage to
start kiting a maneuvering the infected
to your advantage if you're being chased
by a mini horde try to get yourself out
of harm's way by bundling yourself for a
window naturally the undead will follow
your sounds around the building so try
to maneuver them into position just
outside of a window so you can poke away
with your pointy stick with relative
ease my favorite thing to do is to fling
Spears or really any other object from
safety as they claw at me and a cheeky
exploit you can do in this scenario is
to recover your weapon through the wall
while you stay just out of reach it's
real easy to get wounded in scum one
long fall one zombie swipe one quick
slash and you're going to have a boo-boo
you need to take care of keep an eye on
spare clothes aren't too damaged so you
can turn them into ranks to use as
bandages it's a good idea to keep a few
on you and you can and even if you never
get hurt they can be torn up further
into strips to be used as rope or use as
kindling to start a fire
this might be because I'm a stupid human
or more likely new to the game by
accidentally threw my best weapon away
on more than one occasion if your bags
full then you might as well carry your
weapon in your hands to save space right
but if you do anything like climb a
ladder eat some food through another
tool you'll naturally drop it on the
ground to free up your hands so if
you're carrying a lot keep an eye on if
you've got all your kits so you don't do
what I did and leave your brand new
barbed wire baseball bat at the bottom
of a ladder it's a good idea to set up a
shelter with some storage so when you
never to be died you're not back to the
bright orange overalls with nothing but
empty hands and an empty stomach if
you're playing single-player you don't
really need to worry too much about
where you set your head but multiplayer
other inmates will be able to loot your
storage if you don't hide it well enough
look for areas that are near points of
interest that will allow you to spawn
and loot up but also areas that have
decent cover try to get your shelter and
storage into bushes and don't have them
too close this way any wonder is
happening upon them may not find that
aku thing keeping safe
scum has a lot of similarities to Daisy
but in the latter game if you eat human
meat you get brain prion disease which
basically means you shake and become a
laughing mumbling weirdo in scum there
is no downside to eating people at least
nothing has been added since the game
yet so you never really have to be too
short of food you can murder other
players or infected inmates to your
heart's content
chop them up skewer them roast them over
a fire and fill your belly unless that's
like you know morally weird for you or
something this is a bit matter but
despite the hounding cries of fans scum
does not yet have an autorun key and
you'll be running around the massive map
a lot so here's my solution
[Music]
all right it's not elegant and there's
software out there that will allow you
to map an autorun key but this just
works okay
it looks dumb but you'll be glad you
have it all right that's it for
beginners tips for scum if you have any
tips yourself be sure to leave them in
the comments below if we get enough
clever ones we'll make a follow-up video
using your suggested hints thanks for
watching and if you see me in game don't
try to steal my gear I'll eat you and
I'll put you in the ground mate swear me
mum